Hello! Welcome to Michael's Business English Top Tips.
This month we're looking at Holland's Codes.
Holland's Codes are very useful ways to help us understand our work personality.
By identifying our work personality...
...we can choose the job and work activities that will maximize our job satisfaction.
There are six personality types of the Holland's Codes.
Realistic.
This type are people who prefer working with their hands.
Physical, mechanical, engineering kind of work.
Second, investigative.
These people like more intellectual activities such as science and research.
Third, artistic.
These people prefer creative, original kind of work and activities.
Fourth, social.
This type enjoys working with other people.
Maybe as a teacher, carer, social worker, etc.
Fifth, enterprising.
These people like competitive kinds of jobs and activities that are goal oriented.
All of business leaders fall into this type.
Sixth, conventional.
These people like working with data, figures, numbers, etc.
Now, all of us fall under maybe not just one, but two or three of these types.
First, we should try to identify,...
...think which types best match us.
This will help us choose the kind of job and work that we will enjoy.
Secondly, list up what we do in our work,...
...then we can identify which ones match our personality type.
And finally, develop our work personality.
By understanding our work personality,...
...we can see which areas should we improve and develop.
For example, maybe social skills.
This can further help us to maximize our job satisfaction.
Thank you and good luck!